quel est selon vous le nombre de faux
compte que facebook a supprimé de sa
plateforme en 2019
inutile de me donner un chiffre précis
en terme d'ordre grandeur à combien
estimez vous le nombre de faux comptes
ainsi enlevé de la plate forme sachant
que facebook cherche à avoir un compte
par utilisateur humain
d'après vous parle t'on de milliers de
faux compte retirer de dizaines de
milliers de faux comptes 2 millions ou
de quelque chose d'autre encore depuis
maintenant une bonne décennie
les réseaux sociaux font désormais
partie de notre quotidien à chaque fois
qu'on sort nos téléphones ou couvre nos
ordinateurs
bon nombre d'entre nous recevons des
notifications ou regardons les fils
d'actualités de facebook twitter ou
youtube de manière parfois instinctive
et sans se poser trop de questions
pourtant derrière chaque nouveau poste
facebook chaque nouveau tweet et chaque
nouvelle vidéo que vous voyez il ya en
fait une histoire extrêmement complexe
qui vient de l'interaction entre de
nombreuses entités plus ou moins
bienveillante et d'un tri algorithmiques
effectuées par des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle les plus
sophistiqués qui n'ait jamais existé
à chaque fois que vous voyez un message
sur ces plateformes il ya eu de
nombreuses forces en jeu pour que vous
voyez ce message et pas un autre
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais insister sur
la nature des forces en jeu pour essayer
de vous convaincre et qu'elle n'agisse
est généralement pas du tout dans votre
intérêt ni dans celui de l'humanité et
par conséquent à cause de tout cela il
me semble devenu urgent de considérer
que les réseaux sociaux sont devenus
dangereux voire très dangereux dangereux
pour les utilisateurs mais aussi et
surtout pour la santé publique et la
sécurité nationale via le cyber
harcèlement la mésinformation médical ou
encore la radicalisation idéologique les
réseaux sociaux cause déjà d'horribles
souffrances de nombre d'essais et des
préoccupations majeures pour le futur de
l'humanité
pour bien mesurer la dangereux
des réseaux sociaux il est utile de se
rendre compte des enjeux que ces réseaux
sociaux représentent désormais pour
toutes sortes d'acteurs plus ou moins
bienveillants et qui de mieux pour en
parler qu'un général quatre étoiles de
l'armée américaine interviewé par smart
heures everyday numérique depuis
maintenant au moins une demi décennie
les réseaux sociaux sont devenus un
terrain de bataille pour les forces
militaires des rapports du congrès
américain ont ainsi identifié des
campagnes de désinformation organisée
par une agence russe appelée linked
notes whissell agency ou liera pendant
les campagnes présidentielles
américaines de 2016
de façon perturbante cette agence a
produit et partager des contenus à la
fois contre le parti républicain est en
faveur du parti républicain aux états
unis clairement leur objectif n'était
pas de s'allier à l'un des deux grands
partis américains
l'objectif de lits rassembler davantage
d'aggraver la polarisation aux états
unis en produisant en partageant et en
payant pour la diffusion en temps que
publicité de contenu extrêmement clivant
qui tantôt caricature le mouvement black
ice man
et qui tantôt caricature le camp opposé
ce faisant l'agencé russe a certainement
affaiblir les états unis aussi bien sur
le plan politique que sur le plan
économique et alors on pourra se dire
qu'il s'agit là d'un vestige de la
guerre froide entre deux ennemis
historiques
cependant cette cyberguerre qui vise à
modifier les perceptions du grande
publique d'un pays c'est très largement
généralisée depuis 2016 le dernier
rapport du computationnelle propaganda
research project d'oxford paru en 2021
liste désormais 81 pays dont des
activités de désinformation organisée
sur les réseaux sociaux ont été révélés
et si vous lisez ce rapport vous verrez
que la france et la suisse ne font pas
partie de cette liste
mais bien sûr ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
n'ont pas de campagne de désinformation
s'ils n'apparaissent pas dans cette
liste c'est probablement davantage parce
que les services de désinformation de
ces pays ont réussi à ne pas se faire
détecter plus généralement il faut bien
tenir compte du fait que ces campagnes
de désinformation organisée ou d
incentive énorme à rester secrète
comment par le ce livre du professeur
samuel roullé chercheurs sur les
propagandes du web
l'ampleur de la désinformation est
probablement bien plus importante encore
que ce que le rapport du
computationnelle propagande a witch
project révèle de façon inquiétante la
désinformation organisée grandit et se
professionnalise le rapport liste ainsi
48 pays qui ont fait appel à des
entreprises privées pour effectuer ce
travail de désinformation ces
entreprises vont typiquement alors créé
de nombreux faux comptes gérés soit par
des bots soit par des fermes de troll
humains payer pour amplifier la
désinformation
mais les gouvernements semblent loin
d'être les seuls à s'engager dans ces
campagnes de désinformation les
entreprises privées ont elles aussi des
incentive énorme à favoriser telle ou
telle croyance dans l'opinion publique
comme cela l'a été révélée dans le cas
de l'industrie du tabac
d'ailleurs début 2021 le new york times
a révélé une campagne de désinformation
de l'entreprise huawei qui visait à
décrédibiliser un projet de loi belge
sur la régulation des antennes 5g huawei
avait ainsi créé 14 faux comptes
prétendant être des experts en
télécommunication qui partageaient des
critiques du projet de loi
sachant qu'un contrat de milliards de
dollars étaient en jeu pour l'entreprise
à bien y réfléchir il n'est probablement
pas étonnant que huawei a investi dans
cette campagne
cependant huawei est loin d'être la
seule entreprise avec des incentive
énorme à influencer l'opinion publique
google a récemment cherché à terre la
controverse suite au démantèlement de
son équipe des tic et est même allé
jusqu'à modifier
ces algorithmes pour faire disparaître
l'onglet news lorsqu'un utilisateur
américain recharge timide que brou
sachant le contrôle que cette entreprise
a déjà sur le web et les incohérences
entre ses déclarations publiques et les
témoignages de ces chercheurs
je parierais centre au flipper google a
massivement investi aux aussi dans des
campagnes de désinformation notamment
pour décrédibiliser l' expertise de
timides groupe et de margaret mitchell
la désinformation organisée peut alors
prendre d'autres formes que la simple
génération et le simple partage de
contenu pour décrédibiliser des voix
discordantes certaines campagnes semble
s'appuyer sur du cyber harcèlement pour
décourager ou espérer rendre hystériques
les opposants à la campagne de
désinformation en envoyant des messages
en privé ou en public certaines
campagnes de désinformation semble
toutefois se contenter de
systématiquement liker et retweeter tous
les messages qui vont dans leur sens ce
qui a le gros avantage de diffuser la
désinformation sans se mettre soi même
en avant et qui permet ainsi d'éviter de
s'exposer ou d'être révélée en fait pour
bien mesurer l'ampleur des campagnes de
désinformation organisée
il est utile de se tourner vers les
résultats des efforts de facebook pour
supprimer les faux comptes
alors d'après vous sachant tout cela
quel est le nombre de faux comptes
retiré par facebook en 2019 quel est
votre pari parisien et bien d'après les
chiffres de statistiques qui sont tout à
fait cohérent avec les chiffres publiés
dans d'autres médias facebook a retiré
six milliards de faux comptes de sa
plateforme en 2010 9 6 milliards de faux
comptes
c'est énorme c'est presque le nombre
d'humains sur terre en particulier
c'est beaucoup plus que le nombre
d'utilisateurs humain de facebook sur
facebook la majorité compte sont des
faux comptes et ça c'est facebook qui a
une politique d'un compte par hu man qui
a désarmé d'ingénieurs pour identifier
les faux comptes et les retirer et qui a
des incentive important venant des
annonceurs pour que les publicités
publiées sur facebook conduisent à des
achats sur d'autres plateformes comme
twitter réside ou par leur la proportion
de faux comptes et certainement beaucoup
plus importantes sur ces plateformes
surtout sur des sujets polarisant et
surtout venant de comptes anonymes
il faut sans doute s'attendre à ce que
la désinformation organisée soit en fait
la norme
les réseaux sociaux sont sans doute
envahit par des campagnes de
désinformation et ça ça les rend
extrêmement dangereux
en fait il semble utile de considérer
réseaux sociaux sont une sorte de
territoire que beaucoup d'entités
veulent conquérir pour bien comprendre
la bataille qui a lieu il est nécessaire
de comprendre les caractéristiques du
terrain sur lequel cette bataille a lieu
et s'il y a une caractéristique à
comprendre de ce terrain c'est sans
doute le fait qu'il ait gouverné par la
quête de la tension comme vous voulez
dire en introduction à chaque fois que
vous ouvrez un réseau social sur votre
téléphone ou sur votre ordinateur
le contenu que vous y verrez est le
résultat d'une histoire très complexe
cette histoire implique bien sûr le
créateur de ce contenu qui est donc
possiblement le résultat d'une campagne
de désinformation
mais il est aussi et surtout le résultat
de l'algorithme qui a choisi de vous
montrer ce contenu plutôt que n'importe
lequel des milliards de contenu
disponible sur le réseau social
d'une certaine manière l'algorithme est
alors larbitre de la bataille de la
tension c'est lui qui décide quel
morceau de terrain sera gagné par quels
créateurs de contenu et alors on
pourrait imaginer des algorithmes qui
répartissent le terrain de manière juste
où il cherche à offrir du terrain aux
contenus de qualité mais en pratique ce
n'est pas le cas les algorithmes
aujourd'hui déployés pour répartir le
terrain de la tension sont conçus
quasiment exclusivement pour que les
consommateurs des réseaux sociaux
restent sur les réseaux sociaux sans
tenir compte de la fiabilité
informationnel ou de la sécurité des
consommateurs
si les campagnes de désinformation des
agences russes ou des entreprises
chinoises permettent de garder les
consommateurs sur leurs plateformes
les algorithmes vont promouvoir
massivement ses campagnes de
désinformation les algorithmes veulent
que l'attention des utilisateurs soit
porté sur leurs plateformes
il se contrefoutent de quel parti de la
plate forme sera celle qui aura cette
attention et ça ça a des conséquences
dramatiques
par exemple les investigations suite au
scandale facebook cambridge indique à
nous révéler que de façon perturbante
pour la modique somme de seulement 46
mille dollars
les campagnes de désinformation de l'
agence russe ira où est une efficacité
redoutable affectant ainsi des millions
d'américains
pourquoi et bien parce que contrairement
aux publicités des candidats à la
présidentielle
les publicités de l' agence russes sont
extrêmement aguicheuse et addictives
si bien que utilisateurs exposés à ces
publicités rester généralement plus
longuement sur facebook après avoir
consommé ces publicités ou dit autrement
les réseaux sociaux ont créé un marché
de l'information ou la désinformation
coûte beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins
cher à produire et à diffuser que
l'information de qualité et ça
malheureusement ça a des conséquences
qui vont bien au-delà du cas de la
désinformation comme l'expliquent très
bien veritas yonne les créateurs de
contenu aujourd'hui sont tous énormément
influencé par le succès des contenus
qu'ils produisent consciemment ou non
lorsqu'un type de contenu un énorme
succès les créateurs de contenus vont
alors en prendre note et vont produire
davantage de contenu de ce type
or sur youtube en particulier
l'influencent de l'algorithme succès
d'une vidéo est monumentale de vue sur
trois sur youtube résulte de
recommandations de l'algorithme si cet
algorithme veut qu'une vidéo passable
phase 1 millions de vues il lui suffit
de la recommander massivement des
centaines de millions de fois par
exemple mais donc comme les créateurs
s'adapte au succès de leur contenu
et comme ce succès est en très grande
partie déterminée par l'algorithme selon
veritas y sommes le contenu et
l'algorithme l'ensemble des contenus qui
sont vues sur youtube
est ce que l'algorithme de
recommandations promeut non seulement
via son influence directe mais aussi via
son influence indirecte sur les
créateurs un corollaire de tout cela
c'est que les campagnes de
désinformation qui lie est réduite les
contenus qui vont dans leur sens
ou aussi un succès indirect similaires
non seulement ce faisant ils vont donner
plus de visibilité à certains contenus
plutôt qu'à d'autres mais de façon plus
importante encore ces campagnes de
désinformation vont aussi encourager les
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux à
produire davantage de contenus qui vont
dans leur sens c'est sans doute ainsi
que twitter est devenu extrêmement
polarisée et virulent non seulement ces
contenus sont plus mis en avant mais en
plus leur mise en avant encourage tous
les utilisateurs de twitter
consciemment ou non à être davantage
polarisée et virulent car ces contenus
connaissent plus de succès et flatte
ainsi les goûts des utilisateurs de
twitter et tout cela en tout cas à titre
personnel je le sais très bien puisque
je fais partie malheureusement de ses
utilisateurs
c'est ainsi que les réseaux sociaux sont
devenus une jungle incontrôlées et
incontrôlables et alors si ce n'était
qu'une jungle sans effet sur le monde
extérieur
ça serait peut-être millions cependant
de nos jours cette jungle est devenue
extrêmement dangereuse
non seulement car elle est désormais
dominé par des campagnes
de désinformation mais aussi parce qu'on
y voit triompher le cyber harcèlement
mais informations médicales ou la
radicalisation idéologique qui eux cause
d'horribles souffrances des décès
tragique et des préoccupations majeures
pour le futur de l'humanité
les réseaux sociaux sont dangereux très
dangereux
sachant tout cela il me semble urgent de
protéger l'humanité de ces réseaux
sociaux devenus extrêmement dangereux
bien sûr à titre personnel vous pouvez
vous en éloigner mais comme j'en parle
ici je vous conseillerais davantage
d'avoir une consommation saine et
raisonnée des réseaux sociaux puisque
des études suggèrent qu'une telle
consommation
disons autour d'une heure par jour
surtout aussi à les orienter vers la
création de liens ouvert de
l'information fiable
ça semble une utilisation bénéfiques des
réseaux sociaux nous avons bien sûr
c'est à vous de voir
cependant la dangerosité des réseaux
sociaux n'est pas un problème uniquement
individuelle
surtout quand il s'agit de santé
publique ou de sécurité nationale la
consommation de vos concitoyens peut
avoir des conséquences majeures sur
votre propre santé ou votre propre
sécurité
notamment quand il s'agit de maladies
contagieuses comme le co vite 19 ou de
tensions géopolitiques
dès lors il semble urgent de davantage
réfléchir à comment rendre les réseaux
sociaux bénéfique et pour cela il faut
bien se rendre compte que tout réseau
social qui deviendra influent attire
aura inéluctablement des acteurs
malveillants qui souhaiteront promouvoir
leur idéologie ou leurs produits
le grand défi ce n'est pas de concevoir
des réseaux sociaux qui seront
bénéfiques si tout le monde se comporte
bien
le grand défi c'est de concevoir des
réseaux sociaux qui persisteront à être
bénéfique quand ils seront attaqués de
toutes parts par les groupuscules les
gouvernements et les entreprises les
plus motivés et les plus puissants au
monde en particulier pour y parvenir la
recommandation ou la modération semble
critique d'ailleurs l'exemple récent de
par leur une alternative à twitter avec
une modération minimes qui a été envahie
depuis par des mouvements d'extrême
droite américains qui sont derrière les
émeutes du capitole cet exemple semble
montrer à quel point la modération de
contenu est nécessaire c'est en tout cas
ce qu'ont conclu google apple et amazon
qui ont retirés par leurs de leurs
services car par leur n'avait pas
suffisamment de modération cependant
cette problématique n'est pas restreinte
au réseau social par leur une au hajj
est ainsi poursuivi apple pour ne pas
avoir retiré télégramme une application
de messagerie ou semble-t-il la
radicalisation est beaucoup plus
importante encore
de même une grande partie de la campagne
de désinformation du désormais président
bonnaroo au brésil a eu lieu sur what's
app où il n'y a aucune modération ni
recommandation de contenus des réseaux
sociaux sans modération ni algorithmes
de recommandations semble donc très
vulnérables aux campagnes de
désinformation ou deux
dick alisation en tout cas à ce jour il
semble difficile d'y voir des solutions
robustement bénéfique en fait protéger
les réseaux sociaux de telles campagnes
de désinformation c'est un immense
chantier extrêmement délicat ceci étant
dit l'exemple de taiwan nous montre
peut-être la voie pour permettre des
discussions plus constructives
le gouvernement taïwanais a organisé des
débats publics sur une plate forme
appelée police sur réseau social a la
particularité de donner une importance
majeure à son algorithme de
recommandations et de faire en sorte que
cet algorithme promeuvent davantage les
positions consensuelles de façon
remarquable ceci permet d'avancer
beaucoup plus rapidement dans
l'élaboration de lois efficaces pour
résoudre des problèmes pourtant
controversé notez que cette approche ne
cache absolument pas les désaccords
si beaucoup de gens ne sont pas d'accord
avec les positions qui paraissent les
plus consensuelles aujourd'hui sur la
plateforme
ils peuvent tout à fait le faire savoir
ce qui va baisser le classement de la
position consensuelle et la remplacer
par une position davantage consensuel
qui plus est et surtout la plateforme
fournit de nombreuses analyses
statistiques pour permettre de se rendre
compte à quel point telle ou telle
position et consensuelle et à bien y
réfléchir il s'agit peut être là d'une
bonne solution pour protéger les réseaux
sociaux des campagnes de désinformation
plutôt que de constamment cherché à
rabaisser la désinformation
ce qui semble extrêmement difficile
sachant à quel point la désinformation
est prépondérante
sachant la difficulté de la déconstruire
et sachant qu'elle s'adaptera à nos des
constructions il pourrait être plus
efficace de constamment mettre en avant
l'information consensuelle ou au moins
quand il s'agit de science l'information
davantage fiable et on parlera davantage
beaucoup plus en détail dans les
prochaines vidéos de cette option et des
projets de recherche qui vont dans ce
sens
pour l'heure malheureusement les réseaux
sociaux demeurent dangereux très
dangereux
probablement beaucoup plus dangereux
encore que l'aviation les traitements
médicaux et l'énergie nucléaire pour
lesquelles d'énormes investissements
dans des autorités de certification ou
été mise en place
il me semble dès lors urgent d'en faire
de même pour les réseaux sociaux
m
10 km